if you're not doing something that
stands out and gives hiring managers a
reason to talk to you and genuinely sets
you apart from other recruiters that are
probably just as good as you then
they're not going to talk to you and
there's very few people that actually
have something that's a genuinely unique
talking point welcome back to another
episode of the recruitment mentors
podcast I'm your host Tisha mizzouz and
on this week's episode I was joined by
Oliver Legg he's one of the co-founders
of a recruitment business called aspirin
search so first year he did 1.2 million
dollars income second year was 1.35
million dollars and you end the second
year around like five people around that
they specialize in the cyber security
space and I've known Oliver for a little
while I really respected the journey
that they've been on over the last two
years and in those two years this is
what they've been able to achieve so far
they entirely focus on the US market and
have done that from the very beginning
so we go into the details on how they've
gone about that so we talk about their
BD strategy that has really enabled them
to hit those sorts of numbers which has
really paid off for them and Oliver
gives some really good examples in this
conversation as well what characteristic
concentrates do you believe make up a
highly successful recruiter in today's
market all the reasons that people
always give on here are like 100 right
but
like what we were really trying to do
now is find people that have the
let's get into this week's episode
Ollie welcome to the podcast ah good to
be here especially the the week of your
Rebrand as well yeah it's exciting um
thanks for making the trip I appreciate
it yeah yeah obviously we've spoken a
few times
um obviously spoken to uh Joe as well so
I've enjoyed seeing you know the journal
that you guys have gone on
um I'm really excited to talk today
about this two-year entrepreneurial
Journey that you and Joe been on and
building your recruitment business
together
so I guess just to give everyone
listening some immediate context of you
know where you're at because what we're
going to focus on today is very much the
last two years
um although you've been in recruitment
for uh you know over six years
so first year which would have been
um yeah so first you're in business or
you do it in dollars don't you because
you don't do this everything's dollars
uh so first year you did 1.2 million
dollars in net fee income
um and it was all like you said like 99
perm right yep and then second year uh
was 1.35 million dollars net fee income
um and you end the second year around
like five people
um around that uh six people six people
yeah yeah
um and yeah that was uh that in terms of
Netflix income and then I guess the
other thing so it's all still very much
perm we did our second contract
placement this week okay so okay yeah
yeah a massive contract
um you've you've always and only do the
American Market yep and that's not like
just the East Coast it's like you do
everything us yeah yeah
um and yeah all Pam as I said and your
you know Niche is cyber security
yeah
all right well let's have some fun then
let's um let's first start with like
you know what you really would have had
to think about when hiring for your
business like what what characteristics
characteristics and traits do you
believe make up a highly successful
recruiter in today's market
so all all the reasons that people
always give on here are like 100 right
so the the biggest one's always what
resilience work ethic intelligence
um like a emotional intellect and it's
all all 100 right but
like what we were really trying to do
now is find people that have the the
underlying drive and Mission Focus that
enables them to come back day after day
doing this job because yeah like
recruitment can be [__] sometimes
there's uh there's a lot of hours in the
day even even the good days where it's
it's hard and
if you're not driven to
to really do like big things then
there's much easier ways to make like 50
60k right whereas if your mission
focused on it could be anything it could
be some people just want to be dripping
in like designing gear some people want
to have nice cars nice houses
um some people just want to make sure
they're providing for their family their
wives never have to work so they can
look after their kids like that's my
personal goal for my wife to be able to
always look after my my children and
that's what she's fully on board with as
well
um
and some people just want to retire
really and like recruitment's that job
where it can make all that happen in a
really short time frame but only if
you've got the underlying goal to have
resilience and to have that that the
that that intellect to be able to do it
so I think it's uh everything else can
be taught as long as people have the
underlying drive to make it happen and
what sort of questions you ask to get
to find out if people have that
we don't go deep because everyone's
saying yeah you say oh what what are you
doing it for and everyone's like I want
to want to have loads of money I want to
not worry like I want to buy a house
that's like the de facto answer and I
think it's about going it's just going
that level deeper and and understanding
okay but why and what and have you
actually thought through what you need
in order to do that whereas if it's just
oh yeah I want to buy a house
there's just it's that easy answer right
whereas if they're like yeah I want to
do this I need this amount of money this
is how long I want to do want need until
I do it it's like okay this person's
like they're they're probably thought
it's true yeah it's like a genuine
answer rather than a just easy answer to
give
[Music]
so let's get into this business Journey
then so currently if I'm wrong so you
and Joe worked with each other in the
previous company
yes yes so Joe hired me as a
green facial recruiter resourcer so Joe
how do you you progress the sales
director and then did Joe progress in
that business as well right yeah so it
was um it was another really early stage
so Joe was the first employee of of that
business
um I joined a year later
um yeah small firm um purely focused on
the the UK uh like technical cyber
security Market but yeah Joe and I were
kind of key parts of helping that
business grow um and then we just
thought you know what we want to want to
do things are we and have our our own
mark on things
and then so why don't we just start with
like how because you just said that
there like what was
the initial you know strategy for
ultimately acquiring clients because you
know that's going to be how you're going
to be able to
um you know start
um making money
working jobs having vacancies that you
can feel so what was yours and Joe's
initial plan on one the strategy on you
know how are we going to go about
acquiring clients what's our you know go
to market strategy you know talk to us a
bit about that on like version one of
what what that looks like did you always
know you was going to focus on the
American market like talk to us a bit
about you know how you crafted that and
what that initially looks like
um
so our our initial strategy was always
going to be us um because we didn't we
didn't want to get in the way of our
restrictions like at all so we were like
well the easiest way to do that is focus
on a market we've never even looked at
and
Joe managed to close a a a five-roll
retainer of it was just shy of 140 000
uh the week before our business actually
was incorporated on companies house so
we were we were having to hold off
actually sign in the contract until our
business was officially a business
um so yeah like he he just yeah in
incredible star in in having that in
literally the the day one there was
roles to work
um we we set out to do the same thing as
before just in the US so kind of
technical security roles and we we did
that for the first kind of six months
well no seven eight months or so and
then
we I can't remember exactly how it
happened but it was all it was all Joe
and he he he managed to build a
relationship with Sequoia Capital so
like one of the biggest most prominent
VCS
um and then they introduced us to one of
uh one of their their security vendor
clients
um who were hiring for go-to-market
talent so sale sales engineering uh to
build their their Northern American team
and from that point we kind of had like
uh almost like a Eureka moment we were
like right our our Pure BD strategy now
is going to be focused around building
the underlying relationships
um that all of the hiring managers and
the co-founders of these vendors uh the
the people they actually listen to and
the people that are advising so if we
can get in and build relationships with
the advisors of these vendors then we're
almost going to be the the kind of
default partner
um and that's that's the strategy we've
been doubling down on um ever ever since
my super interesting so it will happen
organically yeah yeah kind of unplanned
um never never intended to have a our
business is now kind of 80 85 go to
market focused oh wow um that was never
the intention before it's all more
technical roles uh yeah so we do we do a
few so we still do some like security
engineering
um and and what we call Enterprise
security which uh we we want to build
that out but we're yeah we we've we've
kind of accidentally built a a business
around the go to market side so we're
just investing a lot into into that well
let's go into that thing because the
fact if that's been pretty pivotal on
being the strategy that you double down
on so like just for everyone uh
listening just to make sure that this
sort of resonates and people understand
so you said uh you know vendors
what does that mean
so a vendor is a business that builds
and then sells a a technology like a
tool
um so they have a they have normally a
software product
um often often a SAS product
um and then in our world it's very
specifically a a cyber security product
which they would then sell to companies
yeah or or government
um yeah there's we given it security we
do quite a lot in the like federal
federal government space so what you're
saying is instead of going directly to
them
because you had that introduction and
that success in a advisor or a you know
a PE firm or you know um that type of
community
uh introduce you to the vendor that like
why was that why was that such a aha
moment was it like because you got
introduced by them they were they're
like trusted you straight away it was a
lot more easier to negotiate you know
good quality times was a lot more
committed like what is it that you
experienced which made you go yeah we
should only be we should only be really
trying to break into accounts this way
so
I'll talk you through the project it was
a it was a four four head count project
um so three Enterprise sales people uh
and then one Enterprise sales director
um to build out their Northern American
Sales team and bearing in mind it was a
it was pretty high value project
um all retained with cancellation
Clauses and like a fully locked in
retain project
um you'd expect you'd need to jump
through quite a few internal Hoops to
get that kind of project signed off and
it was
I wouldn't say it was easy but it was
kind of a case of oh like we trust you
already because you've come through this
recommendation right so the the VC route
has has been huge for us
um which is a trust element you guys
have experienced then that underlying
trust so we I spoke to a cro of one of
our it was a new we didn't Place him but
it was a new cro of one of our one of
our clients
um a couple of months ago he we spoke to
him about 10 days after he joined the
firm and he said his first week he'd had
he reckoned it was about 40 to 50
different
bits of Outreach purely from recruiters
wow so you've got emails phones texts
whatsapps emails
um that these guys are getting
absolutely spammed by and like how the
[__] are they going to choose someone
like they're probably just not they're
just going to ignore people
um but who are they going to listen to
they're going to listen to their advisor
their investor the person that's
integral into their business so if they
come in and they say oh well look you
need to hire sales people this is the
firm you need to use they're going to
trust that um so yeah we've we've
especially in the Market at the moment
and there's there's so much noise like
all the
a lot of the 180 recruiters are now
being told well you've got a BD Target
on your head you've got to go out and do
your own Outreach
they may or may not have been taught how
to do that properly so what you've got
is you've got a huge amount more people
trying to win the roles and speak to
managers than ever before
um
and if you aren't doing anything
differently and if you haven't got like
a a genuine differentiator then like how
on Earth are you going to shine through
the noise so I think that's really
important I think it's important
businesses provide the
provide those tools
to their Consultants yeah can I agree
more so why don't we would you mind if
we just focused on the VC piece because
that's going to be in pivotal and then
we can talk about you know the tools
that you guys have really worked on
developing in your business
that you found to be really effective as
you've
um you know been on this journey for the
last two years so you had that great
experience and you're like we have to
you know like this would be great if we
had more introductions more companies we
could work with
because I trusted us immediately
what how did you then go about
increasing the number of VCS that viewed
you as their you know one of their
recommendations or one of their trusted
Partners when it comes to hiring and
talent and people like how did you
initially think about how are we going
to get more VCS like that to be on board
with us and introduce us like what was
the initial approach
uh a massive slog of Outreach and a
massive slog of trying to get our name
in front of these people
um utilizing any any existing
relationships that we we had and
so we we used to work I say we again
it's so so Joe does most of the the BD
um so he he focuses very very heavily
between him and I he he does most of the
the sales aspect
um
he
has been doing that flat out for
probably a year year and a half now
um just just under a year and a half and
I'd say at the start of this year is
when it really started paying dividends
so there was a long long slog of just
not really getting much for it and
almost almost starting to to doubt it
yeah and and being like is because
they're not quick wins
um it's not a case of I'm gonna call
this hiring manager and I might actually
pick up a roll off the back of one phone
call
so it's it it's been a lot more time
investment
um but
just doing it remotely I don't think
would be effective so we we invest a
huge amount of time and money into
getting in front of these businesses
um so we do multiple trips to the US to
Tel Aviv
um we hold Roundtable dinners with with
founders with uh with VCS
um and it's it's a case of just setting
yourself aside from just cold email or
phone Outreach
um like cold calling absolutely has its
place and it's still really really
effective but you gotta you gotta kind
of supplement it with other initiatives
as well
so what what was Joe finally so
difficult then so are you saying there
sorry like
you know was he struggling to get more
introductions into other vendors or you
know I was curious on like how we like
how have you how many other more VCS
have you managed to build good relations
with so I'd say that now we are
we're the in in the cyber security space
for go to market positions I'd say we're
the go-to of probably about seven or
eight VCS now so what did you find most
difficult to be in those rooms of those
people to
get the chance of being
seen as the recommendation so it's track
record and obviously it's hard to build
a track record without a track record so
it's finding one that will give you uh
almost give you a shot and then once
you've got that got that case study you
you double down on it and you I mean you
like crunchbase is amazing right because
you can go on crunchbase and and our
Angelica are operations lady she's she's
building out like a Google sheet Market
map
um that literally enables us to see well
right we've worked with this vendor or
this this end user whatever whatever
kind of client it is
um
who invests in them because normally if
it's a VC funded firm there's I mean
let's say their series B or C like
there's going to be like potentially
over 10 different investors potentially
even more than that over the years that
have been involved in that company and
you can then see well what other
companies has this individual investor
then been involved in so you're then
taking one one successful project and
you're able to use that as an in to
potentially like multiple multiple firms
all from one ultimate relationship
that's that's really credible because
it's been involved with with the with
the VC
it was the track record of Joe having
like the case studies that he's done
this with he's ever go to market teams
which is why he should trust us
she just had to work really hard to get
get a shot yeah and then when he got a
shot had you guys had to really deliver
absolutely if you so especially when now
we're doing a lot more work in um
in in Tel Aviv in Israel
um so there's a huge Tech and in
particular huge cyber security community
in in Israel
um but it's it's an awesome area to work
because everyone knows everyone and
everyone has an underlying Trust of each
other
um because they've all come out of the
military together but the moment
you you do something wrong or the moment
you fail on a project
it's also spreads throughout that
community so we had a project that in
hindsight we we shouldn't we shouldn't
have taken
um so we had a a devops security company
that was
um I think was a director of marketing
search and they refused to give us
manager contacts they refused to give us
a proper briefing call
um and I'm not I really can't remember
why we even said oh yeah we'll we'll get
you some resumes but we didn't put
proper effort into it so the feedback
then and we um we we tried to reference
uh well we tried to win another company
and they said oh what other Israeli
firms have you worked with oh sure we
gave these names said oh well I'll call
the founder of this firm and what what
does he say he's like oh yeah we we
worked with asthma and they didn't
deliver
so we've now ruined well I wouldn't say
ruined but we've maybe we've made it so
much harder to break into this other
client because of a project that we
didn't even put proper time into and
that then stems down to having
like really really high standards with
what roles you decide to work whether
you're an individual recruiter or
whether you're a business owner and
especially at the moment where like
roles are not as easy to come by like
don't lower your standards in terms of
what you're willing to put time into
yeah I've been like they're definitely
like with you like being willing to say
well unfortunately won't be able to work
on this if we aren't able to do that
this is part of the process an important
part of it yeah if they're not willing
to listen to or take your advice then
chance of filling that are going to be
it's just gonna be really difficult
right
so I've sat down with
um just found a bit on the the VC piece
so I sat down with
um local Jamie weeks who also the
similar market and spoke about this
what he found was I don't know if uh
you've seen this for Joe you and Joe
have spoken about it but uh what he
found was when he did
um you know get an agreement in place
that they were one of the
um uh companies that they would
recommend from a hiring Talent
acquisition standpoint he thought the
floodgates would be opened it wasn't
so there's one thing you know being in
the room and you know right we're gonna
yeah we're happy to recommend you and
then I'm assuming you guys are like you
know you're absolutely buzzing guys we
just got a really big VC you know last
year they invested in 30 different cyber
security vendors like this this could be
huge for us and then there's just
Tumbleweed in terms of you know the the
emails going Hey Joe we've disinvested
in this company or this uh one of our um
you know part of our portfolio really
need support with this
so what then had to happen to maximize
relationships like one that you guys
experience that and two you know what
has what have you what if uh Joe had to
be really good at in terms of like okay
we've worked really [__] hard to be
in the room to be recommended now what
we're doing to really maximize the
opportunity that we've been given so
then it's cultivating the relationship
um so literally making sure that you're
in really regular conversations with
them
um again it really ties into the events
and actually seeing these people and
people in in person so we in in Tel Aviv
we held a uh we held two lunches so we
did a Founder's lunch and then we also
did a a VC lunch and we had I think it
was about 13 or 14 individual VCS from
different and very high profile uh cyber
security investors and these are
companies that Joe has been in contact
with for for a long time
um and now things are starting to happen
so this is far from a
like get rich quick in recruitment BD
scheme it's not but when it does pay off
and as I say it's been starting to pay
off the beginning of this year it's it's
going to be massive
um so we recently got onto the and this
was off the back of two successful
projects
um with uh with with the end vendors
that we did actually win directly with
the vendors themselves so the VC wasn't
involved
um and we're now on what they call the
the the the the the platform or like the
value creation platform
um that one of the largest uh corporate
VCS provide to their vendors so now when
you go onto that platform because a
vendor needs a service you've got
aspiron's name on there right so if you
need Recruitment and then the uh is when
you go to market recruitment these are
the guys that you're going to speak to
so but it takes time we've still not had
any any any value come or any benefit or
roles come off the back of being on that
platform yet but we will
so I think the main thing is just
investing in these these longer term
strategies and just having the belief
that no they are going to pay off whilst
you're also trying to do your your kind
of normal Outreach and and generate uh
direct wins as well as I was going to
say like this I think it's great that
you've had this overarching long-term
strategy which hopefully is can you can
continue building but what have you and
Joe had to really double down on in the
short term to make sure you've got cash
flow and all those things going as well
yes so
um good email sequencing um so this is
where just the the really good sales
strategies come through so really good
email sequencing
um uh definitely heavy on the cold
cooling still like I'm a True Believer
that
um like those old school sales tactics
they still work
um like anyone that says cold calling's
dead so I don't don't believe them in
the slightest
um so so big bigger big lever in that
um we are still able to have very good
wins in terms of just just getting uh
get get getting directly through to
Founders cro CMOS and and picking up
roles that way but they're more likely
to have a lot more competition so it's
then whistling it down again and being
like right well I've won this role but
do I actually want to put time into it
or is it more worth my time to carry on
searching for a better quality role that
I'm more more likely to feel
what
so on that like
America's so big
like what you know how how did you
initially like have a bit of a focus or
Target or did you not because
you know that's why a lot of companies
initially start in certain parts of the
US or certain States or you know like
how did you approach that because there
is so much you can go for like work like
that surely could have been overwhelming
we were in this really fortunate and
probably fairly unusual position where
we had like a massive project on day one
right so we we already had a big focus
it was in um it was a company called
neuro uh they have these uh
driverless robots that drive around like
Texas and California delivering like
Domino's Pizza so it's really really
cool
um
so we we had a focus there straight away
so we were building their automotive
security team and we then built a client
base around that project right okay so
they were they were looking for remote
people I mean they could have been in
California but they were also looking
for remote people so it gave the
opportunity of right we're speaking to
candidates from day one so we've got
people to flip on day one right
um and we managed to build a decent
client base off the back of that and
like these really uh
just just like original recruitment
strategies they're still some of the
best ways like candidate flipping
um like those are what what does that
mean
so being able to speak to us not even a
senior level candidate any candidate and
be thinking what else can I get from
this call so what can you get you can
get referrals or you can get leads so
every candidate knows someone for some
form of role that you have whether
they're actually any good or not is
different but they they do know someone
that they could recommend to you for
something and they will be able to give
you a level of Intel into their company
what's going on hiring who does the
hiring when they are hiring and it's
just thinking I can I can get that
information from every single candidate
every single conversation and and just
just making sure you get it
um and I think
especially now there's so many like
automation tools and so many
like amazing things that recruiters have
that never used to have it's easy to get
away from actually there's some really
core activities that are probably the
most effective ones that a lot of people
then forget to do on a on a consistent
basis um
is there anything else that you think a
lot of people forget today
update the database
um I mean that I know we laugh right but
when you're building out you know a new
market you know a new company
that's you should be excited about that
and take that seriously right
absolutely one of the
one of the biggest things in it is it's
become a lot more important this year is
is just
having regimentally high standards and
the database is one of those things and
um
I think it's especially especially new
recruiters that are new to the industry
they can go on something like why are
you on my back for updating the database
and it's a case of having having really
clear and actually accurate data like
six months a year down the line You'll
benefit from that so when you need to
get a manager's number instantly because
you've just seen they've got a role and
actually you can't because you didn't
put that number on the database and now
you need to search through your whole
Outlook email box your LinkedIn email
box and something that should have taken
you 20 seconds as has has taken you
minutes and it's yeah it's just a case
of those those real Basics you can't
build a really successful recruitment
desk unless you're doing those basic
things right every day
it's a few just a few bits on the on the
US then then Keen to talk to you a bit
about you know you being a business
owner and how you've had to adapt there
and how you've approached you know
growing and building your
your business like you've always so
previously you'd always done the UK
Market
we did a tiny bit of the us at the very
end
um I think I did like three placements
into the states but so yeah Joe Joe did
a few more but very very few and as I'm
sure you've seen like there's definitely
is it's definitely been really popular
for over the last couple of years of UK
companies doing more in the US
like what's been your your experience
you've spoken a lot about you know BD
strategies
um you know the the experiences that you
guys have had but like what what have
you found to be different over there if
anything like you just said you know
just doing really good quality
recruitment Basics and these things are
still so so effective and really
important
so like what have you and Joe found to
be different over there if anything I I
don't think it's that different so
when you when when you look at people
talking about it on LinkedIn like
sometimes there's I feel there's this
misconception that oh I'm going to
instantly start doing the US market and
it's going to be way easier I'm going to
win loads more clients and I'm going to
Triple my fee and like yeah you can
triple your fee with each placement you
do but it's still hard it's no easier
and I don't think it's any harder it's
it's still recruitment it's just into a
brand new market so yeah I'm I I I I I I
I stand by it not being any different
um but you need and again this just
comes back to the the current climate
and the current market like if you're
not doing something that stands out and
gives
it gives hiring managers not so much
candidates but gives hiring managers a
reason to talk to you and and genuinely
sets you apart from other recruiters
that are probably just as good as you at
delivering and finding candidates and
representing people then they're not
going to talk to you
um and there's very few people that
actually have something that's a a
genuinely unique talking point
um but one of the tools that we we give
to to all of our Consultants is we've
got a non-profit initiative so we're
giving
um
well we've got a mentorship and then
like almost like a scholarship program
um that's no fee attached to any any
stage of it's completely funded by by us
um and we have cohorts of of candidates
that are trying to break into the
security industry and then we're also uh
paying for their like three core uh
cyber security certifications so
instantly we're able to say to it when
someone asks you the question of okay
but why are you different
I bet that most recruiters don't have a
genuinely unique answer to that that
doesn't rely on our database or our
ability to find candidates or our work
ethic whereas what we're able to say is
well if you work with us then you're
actually directly funding early stage
cyber security careers
and you can actually especially if
you're in person when you're talking
about that you can see like a noticeable
like changing People they're like oh
okay wow and it allows you that
conversation so I think the most
important thing in in today's market is
making sure that you've got a
you've got something that allows you to
get the foot in the door
um because if all you're doing is
sending cold calls and all you're
sending cold emails and all you're doing
is doing cold calls just npcing or just
speccinging candidates
there's probably 20 other people doing
the same with candidates they're just as
good as yours so you need something that
allows you to stand out and allows you
to get on the phone and give them give
you that time to talk about your
services and what the other tools that
you guys have found work then besides a
non-profit mentoring I love that
initiative that's great because it's
sort of all self-serving isn't it it's a
live move
what you guys are doing trying to get
more people into the industry I just
really goes in line with the mission and
the industry that you're serving but
obviously what what are the other tools
that you found to be effective so
they're the main ones that and the VC
route and being able to leverage some
some really really high profile
recommendations
um within the cyber security ecosystem
they're they're they're they're they're
the biggest things
um I'm probably gonna say the podcast
yeah I forgot about the podcast as well
yeah I'm sitting here in this room I've
forgotten about the uh I've forgotten
about it because I know you guys
into that yeah no you're right how did I
miss the uh how did I miss the podcast
so yeah the podcast has been huge so we
we haven't even been doing it that long
so it was it was this year
um I think we're in terms of published I
think we're like episode 30 or something
so it's not it's not been going that
long
um but we've got it to the stage where
we've got the pr companies that
represent
big security vendors well-known security
vendors reaching out to us asking to get
their clients on so we're actually
getting like proactive requests for
people to come on it
because there's underlying business
value
to these people coming on our podcast so
like we didn't expect that to happen
like we started it as almost like a bit
of fun and to to be able to have those
conversations
um and we're so we're out in
I mean we might have just got back from
from Vegas by the time this this episode
goes live but we're we're out at a big
security conference in Vegas at the
beginning of August
um and we've got something planned
around the podcast for for that week no
the again I won't say what it is just in
case this goes out before uh before they
go out but we've got some some things
that just we haven't seen being done by
other people because there's a lot of
recruitment podcasts out there there's a
lot of really good ones
um so again it's trying to think well
what what do I do to elevate that part I
think it's just trying to stand out at
every single thing you do so how does
that help you guys is it that you can
reach out to people and say hey
we've got this would you be interested
and like how does it work in practice
are you making sure that
you know every time you have maybe a
prep call you speak to him is like this
is what we do as a business this is what
we have like what like how does it how
does it turn into business
so we we don't so directly we don't use
the podcast as a as a BD pitch
opportunity um
because I'm sure a lot of people do and
I think the moment you
I think the moment you do that it almost
becomes false and it becomes okay so you
just had an underlying agenda of having
me here it's like if after this you I
mean maybe you're gonna but if if after
this you pull means uh in into rumor
like right here's a 10 minute demo on
recruitment mentors on on hexan yeah
sorry
um but all right so like this was purely
just so you can have an opportunity to
pitch me to get my business and it it it
it almost like makes a relationship and
the whole the whole recording seem a bit
false right if that were to happen so so
that's that's not how we use it
um but it's it's relationships it's been
able to know that actually I can now
call you and we've done this thing
together where I reckon you'll now
answer a call to me and we can have a
conversation where at a time it makes
sense like we can then talk about the
business side of it and we can talk
about how we can have a commercial
agreement but I don't I don't think
doing it in an intake call or before or
after the podcast is the right the right
thing to do this podcast is proudly
partnered with vincere the all-in-one
recruitment agency software that over 20
000 recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning one-up
sales and motivation platform that
enables you to maximize the potential of
your teams we love partnering with both
of these organizations because they
share our mission in helping you get the
most out of your people and your
business you can get exclusive offers
because you listen to this podcast and
get up to 10 of the usage price forever
use a link in the show notes to get your
hands on that let's get back to the
episode
Okay so we've we've covered a lot of the
details on like assuming all of these
types of things have equated to what
you're able to do
you know a million back to back in terms
of net fee income right
so let's just talk about how have you
had to grow up as a business owner in
these past two years you know what I
mean because being an employee you know
growing someone else's business is
different to you enjoy running your own
business
so I think something that you said to me
on the prep course is quite interesting
so you said by the second year there's
like six of you said didn't you right
yeah so
so I think you said to me on the prep
call
uh you've you you it was like the
opposite of what I normally hear which
was I think you said crap if I'm wrong
you said
I felt like I tried to get away from
being in the business too quickly and he
was so set on
only working on the business
whereas a lot of recruitment owners that
I speak to feel like they're too much in
it and want more time on it but you sort
of have had I don't know how recent this
has been but like you were saying to me
that yeah I think we actually went too
far that way yeah so why didn't why
don't we start there like what's been
yeah like where where did that come from
and you know what what were you trying
to do which maybe now you're actually
having a bit of a different approach to
it
um
so
towards well probably middle towards
yeah like Q3 Q4 last year so 20 22.
um we built a really really strong
client base the market was absolutely
flying
um and it was a consistent client base
um Joe and I were very much focused on
the vast majority of business we were
able to pick up and we were able to win
let's pass it straight down right so
let's give it to our Consultants let's
spread it out and let's build the let's
build the business that way
um and so we we've got a
we um I'm sure you know Mike wattman
um from um
I can't remember the name of his uh
before his head agent works from himself
yeah yeah yeah he's got a name for it
though but I can't he'll he'll shoot me
for for not remembering but anyway we've
got a recruitment coach Mike want many
brilliant absolutely brilliant um but I
think we probably took one of the things
he said a little bit too too literally
um and in terms of the world as a
business owner you want to concentrate
on working on rather than in and I think
we just took we took a bit too much of a
step away in the goal of being able to
kind of really feed and and fuel the
growth by passing the roles down I think
that what that what that probably did is
bearing in mind we've technically hiring
three people as 360 Consultants is it
might have created slightly the wrong
mindset in terms of oh like now we
should be expecting these positions
um and we've still been able to so so
um give a couple of examples So like um
uh so so Tanya one of our senior
Consultants she was able to win a
hundred and
it was about 155 000 worth of retained
work which she successfully filled off
the back of a trip to the US a trip to
San Francisco
um completely new business and um one of
our other other senior Consultants Brody
like he uh he's on track for Target this
year which is a very good thing to say
given this Market I think for a lot of
for a lot of recruiters
um and about 80 of that is independently
360. so I think it was just then that
kind of shift in the mindset of actually
Joe and Ollie are going to come back
onto working in the business
um not completely I wouldn't call myself
like a 100 full-time recruiter you can't
be but I think it was important to to
kind of get back to being Hands-On
um
also from the like the enjoyment
perspective they missed recruiting
missed speaking to candidates and and
closing candidates and that buzz of like
oh I've just like closed an absolute
belter um so I think it was important
for for everyone
um that Joe and I just become like right
we've probably stepped a bit further
than we should have done let's let's get
let's get let's get back to to really
driving it from from the from the front
rather than trying to trying to kind of
feed it from from the back how did you
go about
changing that mindset because I
literally spoke to the recruitment
company the other day that felt the
exact same way
you've they've got a team of people
who have got used to
being given roles I've earned good money
uh but now
trying to drive them to you know pick up
their own business or be motivated to do
that
um
and they're struggling to do that or
just on that motivator because they're
like oh no audio sort me out we'll get
improved roll through or Joe's gonna
Joe's gonna pull a role a joke and just
do more BD how did you go about starting
to change that
getting closer to like kpis really
getting closer to metrics
um and like we're far from a
like I don't know your your traditional
like Boiler Room kpi shop where it's
like right you have to do three hours of
cool times before you go home or you
have to send 10 CVS if you want to leave
on a Friday like we're far from that
um but we do have a we do have a big
emphasis now on these are the metrics
that you should be hitting if you're
going to be building a successful 360
desk and I think it's just having the so
we we have
one of the other things that we've
learned over the over the last 18 months
of actually having a team
um is what kind of meeting structure do
we want and what kind of management
structure do we want and it's it's taken
quite a long time and quite a lot of
like chopping and changing to to settle
on where we're at now but we're pretty
confident now that we've like locked it
down and it's it's it's working so we
have like weekly pledges at the start of
the week yeah so everybody yeah we do
key objectives but I actually really
like that word yeah
on a Monday and
the pledges are separate from the kpis
because the pledge the kpis well this is
what this is what I kind of need to be
doing is what good looks like yeah
whereas the pledges like this is what
I'm actually aiming to do and and this
is the
this is the meaning and this is the the
context behind the kpi so for example
when I'm going to deliver X number of
CVS to this specific role
um I'm going to try and convert this
specific uh a prospect I've been
speaking to
um and then I'm going to do our uh this
type of specific out let's say you're
doing a a NPC so most uh spec out I'm
specifically sending this candidate to X
number of this type of business yeah and
then it's really easy to then be like
okay well halfway through the week right
where are we at on Wednesday yep so
another another meeting on Wednesday
um where we're just kind of taking stop
on right where are we at
um and things change like you might have
had a new role coming so it also enables
you to kind of recalibrate on what the
priorities are for the week and then on
a Friday
um it's then a case of there's a
was 20 left of the week right like still
a still an important day
um it's right what have we got left to
do so let's make sure we drive that
forward and we literally since we've
kind of locked in on that structure
there's been such a difference in the
team um and also in terms of them
feeling feeling a bit more ownership and
a bit more responsibility over the
pledges which in turn help achieve the
kpis
um I really love that we do something
similar it was taken from this podcast
with uh weekly key objectives on the
Monday a Wednesday Pit Stop session
hurry on track with things and then
Friday don't have a me invert very much
sort of communicate in the morning when
when you do like the more management
stuff as well in terms of one-on-ones
these types of things you do that weekly
or so we do one-on-one so I I tend to do
um the one-on-ones which is straight
after the morning kickoff the Monday
kickoff meeting yeah we always do a a a
one-to-one so that's then much more
around well what what are you actually
because we don't you don't want to be
sitting on a team meeting listening to
someone else's incredibly detailed
granular plan which if you like if
you've got a reasonable size team like
you're sitting there for an hour and
only like 10 of the meetings relevant to
you so you've Switched Off
um so we try and keep the the team
kickoffs like very much short to the
point
um and then the one-on-ones go into much
more detail of right like what do you
need to do and what what do you need
from me and what do you need from Joe to
enable you to do that
um so we found that works as well but
there's definitely been a lot of
there's been a lot of chopping and
changing and it's it's definitely
created some
up until the last last couple of months
it's definitely created some kind of
inconsistency because it's probably like
I've join only have another another
great idea on how to how to do our
weekly structure
um but they're so impactful when you get
those right yeah and I feel we're there
now
um it's just it's taking a taking a bit
of time but we came from a business
where there was nothing like there was a
there was a Monday there was a Monday
meeting like 8 A.M on a Monday
um where we talk about activity
um and that that was it so we we we
learn all we've been learning all of
this as we go like we're not like I mean
was it Sam Sam Perry from from salt or
soda um you had him on Ollie Perry yeah
yeah that's that's it um
so like their structure is great and we
took a lot from that in terms of
actually do you know what the structure
that we're now creating actually seems
aligned with what a really successful
business yeah is doing so it gave a bit
of confidence in terms of actually I
think we're I think I think I think
we've got it I think we've got it right
now it's just about like like we said
we're talking about driving performance
right and there's got to be that element
of
people having autonomy and wanting to
you know achieve the performance and
then from a leadership management
perspective holding people account or
having ways of 100 accountable whilst
also then having systems in place in the
business to help these people to perform
better right and one of them is getting
people set up for the week having them
understand what their priorities are
these things
on the just just to round this out then
what what are like the important kpis in
your business then like you know what
have they ended up being I don't know if
they've evolved like what what's like
the dashboard you know what's on those
metrics on the dashboard that you look
like in terms of uh that you look at
which you know identify what good looks
like out of interest I'm just curious so
the the most important things that we
care about is first interviews yeah uh
per week and then BD engagements per
week
BD engagements which is defined by three
things okay so we Define a BD engagement
as either a new pitch so you've actually
had a sit down like pitch call with a
prospect
um you have either won a new qualified
role or you have uh signed the terms of
business so what that means and the
reason we've done it is two is really
you should always be aiming to have one
pitch per week but if you're sitting
there on a
Thursday or a Friday and you're like oh
I've not I've not been able to do any
successful BD
you can still go back through and you
can chase all of the people that have
outstanding terms that for whatever
reason haven't got back to you so you've
got an opportunity to still achieve it
there but you've also got an opportunity
to go back through all of your existing
managers all of your existing client
base and potentially pick up a role
so
we thought it's it's unrealistic to have
just two pitches per week because if
it's the end of the week you probably
can't immediately get a proper BD pitch
but you can spend an hour calling you
all of your existing clients and you can
win a role so we're still making it
achievable towards the end of the week
with minimal time left so be the
engagement and first into first
interviews and then we measure loads of
other stuff obviously but the ones
they're the ones that they're the ones
that really matter you see those there's
like the lead Dominator towards the
outcomes if you're doing if if you're
consistently doing
I mean uh well we we target it as a
minimum of three in our Market that's
that's that's fine for us a minimum of
three first interviews on qualified
roles per week like you're you're doing
deals
how else have you had to
evolve as a business owner and have
evolved that mindset
what else have you really had to learn
on the job or get better at or improve
on
now we've spoken about you know BD
strategy is how you've gone about that
we've spoken about driving performance
managing people
what else have you and Joe really had to
that maybe you've been surprised by or
you know how have you how else have you
had to like yeah like grow up as a
business owner
so all the back office bits the like you
have zero exposure to as a as a
recruiter you have absolutely no idea
what or how much goes on in the
background
um and we we launched our business
through recruit Hub so Edmund and and
the team and they've like they're
fantastic
um so they provide all of like the
technology all of the the tech stack and
all of the tech support behind that
um and then they also provide the so we
didn't take investment from them but
they they provide the the platform and
the um like the back office support so
all of that being in one place is a
massive help but there's still so much
you have to do
um so like just like payroll
um like looking through Finance like the
tax side of things
um like making configuration changes
within cherry or sourceware or Source
breaker like all of these things that
they take ages
um like call in the bank
yeah spend hour and a half on the phone
so to why he's trying to sort out an
issue with our USD card for for our trip
to San Francisco a couple of months ago
and it's like I've just lost an hour and
a half of my time
to sort out a bank card and it's all
those little things that that add up and
if if we were to launch again I'd I'd
probably I'd make this one of our very
first hires and that's operations really
so the the single most impactful hire to
the whole business and to Joe and I has
has been Angelica our operations lady so
what she does and what she's able to do
like in terms of the podcast and in
terms of a lot of the stuff that was
bogging Joe and I down is is huge so
I'd I'd definitely make that as like
Beyond like your first two actual
recruiters I'd I'd be hiring operations
and I'd be building that underlying
infrastructure that enables you to scale
what does that look like then
so playbooks training
um
uh like
I still need to do a lot of this but
like flow charts of
um exact processes that enable you to
not have to do one-on-one training for
every single step of the process so
there's loads of stuff that should be
done in person like the sales aspect and
the actual like candidate and the the
talent and the the client management
that should all be done by by person but
then there's loads of stuff like the the
tools in the process and the like the
sequencing the that you can just you can
almost automate the training of that
just by spending the time to build out
in the first place it's just doing all
the upfront work that then
you can use multiple times until it's a
bit outdated you don't truly realize
that until you've done it manually six
seven times and you'll think I could
have just done this once so what else do
you what else do you put I'll just I was
just curious on like what you view
makes up the infrastructure to help you
guys grow whatever that looks like so
you've sent playbooks systems and
processes how we do things training yeah
what else do you view in that journey of
like these are the things that we need
to
you know invest time and get done that
we're going to thank ourselves for in a
year two years three years time I mean
what everything you said at the main
ones is just it's doing it properly
right so like a lot of the things like
we we did but we did them half-assed and
they weren't actually usable so they
were or they weren't they weren't
complete so when we tried to use them it
was then uh actually there's still loads
of gaps missing so now I need to go back
and redo it manually yeah and then I
also need to redo the the actual like
the Playbook so I think it's just that
that upfront time especially as you're
growing and
like you're still trying to generate
Revenue to keep the lights on it's
really hard to set aside a few days to
do something that's not generating you
Revenue like in the remote immediate
future
um
but if you are looking to scale and hire
a lot then it will you'll you'll you'll
find yourself like a few months down the
line you use the word Playbook there
um obviously I feel like because of the
world that you guys are in that that's
fairly normal language
um
so so like for me you know when I think
of the word Playbook and how I've used
that in my business we've got a sales
Playbook we've got a customer success
Playbook we're building a marketing
Playbook so from a sales standpoint if
you go into our sales Playbook you're
going to be able to see our sales
process you're going to be able to see
our talking tracks and scripts for the
different parts of the sales process
you're going to be able to see our case
studies our testimonials etc etc what
does playable mean for you because you
sort of chucked that in there and not
everyone will be aware of that so like
when you say Playbook what does that
consist of so so first of all we've got
so the playbooks is part of this but
we've got uh like an internal like
intranet so we've got and we call it a
knowledge base so we've got a Sonu klino
so really good tool so we use notion
notion yeah yeah
um
So within that we've got it's designed
to be whatever you need as a consultant
you can go and find it yeah so it's
everything from case studies
um from uh like search strings it works
to be fair you don't need the next we've
got Source breaker um so that that one's
null and void but um there's also like
every form of like document so rather
than asked like shouting out to the
office has anyone got a candidate cool
sheet or has anyone got a qualification
sheet whatever it might be like everyone
just knows it's in one place yeah and
that that's that's a huge help
um but then within that is is the
Playbook so we have
um I mean you could call it training
right it's playbook's a training but I
think it's
it's Maurice
it's more specific because the way I
view a Playbook is
I could hand this to you and say go and
read this and action it and you should
be able to do it yeah it's like how we
do things yeah start like what's been
working like what's working and how will
you do things so like yeah that's why I
was interested in how you viewed it
um so we we have them for like one of
them one of the main ones we have is the
like the cold email Outreach and well
not not just email the cold Outreach for
for sales and the the process and the
structure and then
kind of bringing in Source way on
exactly this this is how you should be
structuring your your Outreach
um and that's what we're getting the
good responses from so yeah it it works
but it takes it takes time and it takes
time to build but you can it it quickly
builds yeah it's just it honestly is
crazy to me that uh like so many rural
recruitment teams and smaller ground
recruitment businesses won't have
anything like that we didn't have
anything like we had we had a phone and
a links in recruiter license and email
and like some job boards and beyond that
there was there was no we didn't come
from an environment where there was any
form of training there was any form of
structure it literally was a case of
like there's your target go and do it
like there was there was
our bosses were great in terms of if
you're going to ask them something
they'd always give you the advice but
there was no like set this is this is
how we do things
um
and especially as we as we grow and as
we continue to build I think it's so
important yeah so like it's crazy just
because
I speak to like so like for me I don't
know what you think about this but like
if you're listening to this right now
and you have nothing like that that's
fine what we're saying is like use the
people around you this is what I think
is such a missed opportunity like if I
think of when I was in the business I
was and it was eight people
uh you know the the top performer that
sat next to me
like I didn't know what was working for
them like they could be specking out a
candidate in a certain way using a
certain subject line using certain
personalization that could help me
[__] open up doors and I have no clue
about it I have no idea about it so I
think for me when I speak to companies
they do you know they have nothing like
that like I say one I think that's a
missed opportunity because you know have
you ever have you ever have you and your
team ever asked your top performers like
what's working for them and why they
think it's working for them and is that
knowledge being passed around the office
because if it isn't like why would you
not use that information that's in your
four Wars and like if you want to just
try and get better at bringing that out
a good just First Step you don't have to
build a playable Crimson the good first
step is get time in the diary with the
team and let's all go around the the as
a group and just share what one thing is
really working for me right now on the
sell side or on you know qualifying
whatever it may be so we each of us
within go to market there's there's a
few different areas and each of our team
have a they're not they're not set to it
but they they have their areas that they
gravitate towards
um and they're quite different like if
you're qualifying a marketing role and
you're doing it well you need to know
you need to get different informations
with your qualifying sales role
um so we build out and we we ask the
team we ask their their input because I
don't know that much about marketing
um whereas
um
people in the business know no huge
amounts about it and we then build out
well these are the things that are
important to a hiring manager these are
the things that are important to a
candidate when hiring for sales people
when hiring for sales engineering people
when hiring for marketing people so now
if you like we could give you the
qualification sheet for sales and even
if you'd never qualified a sales role
before you would be able to qualify
someone to the absolute Max just by
asking the questions that are on the
Playbook so that's so valuable right um
so what what's on the horizon then as we
round this out what's on the horizon for
you guys we're moving to uh to
Bournemouth we're uh yeah we've had a
big big change in the business the last
uh the last two months
um so we've we've made the decision to
to shut the Crawley office
um I'm so Joe's always lived down there
um and I think we realized that actually
the two Founders only seeing each other
once a week
in an office-based firm originally
didn't just just there it just wasn't
quite it wasn't quite clicking
um there was never major issues but it
was just like we're not as effective as
we could be so we now very much have a
remote and flexible first environment
um so
um the the we've still got the office in
Crawley at the moment
um when that shuts it will be a case of
the the team can very much work remote
um we just asked them to come down and
everyone be together a few few days out
of the month
um and yeah we're uh we're we're going
to be growing significantly down there
um it was kind of all all part of I
think when
it's difficult to get blinded by it but
when when you realize that something's
not necessarily clicking as it should
and when you realize that there's a way
to be more effective even if it has some
element of like business impacts like
positive or negative you just gotta do
it and even if there's because we we had
a a as expected we had a bit of Fallout
from that decision of course we did
we've just told people we're shutting
the local office and we're moving 100
miles down on the south coast
um but I think it's that bigger picture
of Joe and I know that for him and I
being back together is going to
transform and make us so so so much more
effective and the people that are on
board with that they realize that it's
going to make things so much better for
them as well
um in terms of what opportunity we'll be
able to provide them
honest this is Joe's grand plan all
along yeah maybe he's just been uh
waiting to drag me down so what what are
you guys what what are you guys doubling
down on then over the next you know to
make as like a lot of people said it's
been a difficult start what you and Joe
really focusing on and doubling down on
making sure you have really high
standards around to to end this year on
a positive so yeah I mean where you
mentioned standards huge emphasis on
high standards in every aspect of the
business
um huge aspects of uh of of of of
accountability to those standards as
well
um we're as we have been doubling down
on the the non-profit initiative we're
doubling down on the trips
um uh yeah we'll we'll get people on
planes as often as they can be effective
getting on on planes to the US also
Israel or to to waypac if they wanted to
build an apat desk
um and very much focusing on uh on on
hiring experience remote Talent uh
across the UK
um and then trainee Talent
um or experience Talent Downer down on
the south coast yeah
all it's been a pleasure likewise mate
thank you very much